[Music]
[Music]
it's a real pleasure to welcome Bob
Laughlin back to MIT bob was an
undergraduate at Berkeley but he came to
MIT to do his graduate work his graduate
thesis was done here with John Joe
Annapolis he then moved on to Bell Labs
for a while
lawrence livermore before he finally got
a faculty position which he still has at
Stanford University Bob is best known
for his theory of the integer quantum
Hall effect followed by his theory of
the fractional quantum Hall effect for
which he shared the Nobel Prize in 1998
with the two experimenters who
discovered the fractional quantum Hall
effect horse Dermer and Dan Suey Bob has
traveled extensively he has been a
spokesman for science in a number of
different areas he spent two years in
South Korea as the president of the
Korea advanced Institute for science and
technology he has recently written a
popular book on the philosophy of
science a book called a different
universe not an alternate universe to
understand different universe with the
subtitle reinventing physics from the
bottom down now I know that that's a
well-read book because just in the the
break someone came up to me
spontaneously and mentioned that Bob he
had read your book and he enjoyed it
very much so he was looking forward to
what you were going to tell us
[Applause]
morning everybody obviously it's a great
pleasure to be back at MIT a place where
things change but also many do not such
as numbering the buildings however
that's good because then you know right
where you stand now when I got asked to
speak for this event I did a little
thinking about the topic because it's
rather important I tried to imagine what
was the intent of the people who lobbied
to get the money the people who donated
the funds to build a center and more
generally what the vision of the center
is in the context of physics with a
small P and the title I came up with was
Renaissance physicist that is to say
physicists who know a lot of things so
let's talk about that a little bit
because that's pretty clearly what the
center is all about it's about we talk
about bringing together and so forth why
would you want to do that however what's
to be gained by bringing together after
all you work pretty well apart for a
long long time and there's an old saying
about machines of course if it ain't
broke don't fix it so the question you
can ask is well what are you fixing and
what is the objective really of the
center and I must alert everybody that
this talk actually by design is directed
at the younger people
more than the old Fudd's because the
problem I'm going to talk about is your
problem not the problem of your academic
forebears now I will take off my MIT hat
a minute and put on my Stanford hat and
tell you that MIT is not the only
organization that is worried sick about
this problem Stanford also has gone to
great lengths to try to bring the
branches of physics together in some
ways more successfully than others
my my informant of physics professor
sein herring who's now not there
completely - felt the same way that that
we are trying to invent physics with a
small pea that's what we're trying to do
as intellectuals and we're always
fighting this intrical forces that try
to make it not happen he didn't succeed
and I think it's fair to say that a lot
of people who have omnivorous interests
haven't succeeded either the reason of
course is the funding algorithm with
which we interact with government and
also historical patterns and the reason
we need to think hard about this problem
is of course that the historical milieu
was changing that's exactly what Shirley
was was talking about when she mentioned
the rather dark clouds on the horizon
for science the division of labor in
science and technology that we're
familiar with is in fact a cold war
legacy and like many things that are
cold war legacies it's going away in
part
at least I think so in other words that
the physics departments that don't
create physics with a small P won't
survive so it's very important now we
might ask the question if there had been
no World War two and no Cold War why
would we have physics departments after
all the science that really makes the
heart of industrial people beat is
chemistry and of course it's
doppelganger materials science material
sciences and engineering departments now
basically it's solid-state chemistry
there's a lot that happens in materials
and in organic chemistry that are kind
of magical and unpredictable and you can
make a lot some lots of money selling
them and so our industrial friends are
mainly concerned about that also
engineering Electrical Engineering
mechanical engineering particular to be
strong disciplines despite the heavy
challenges that are coming to us from
the Far East well there are two reasons
I think and of course this is something
that all of us who are in physics have
to think through I'm going to give you
my my personal opinion it has to do with
the topic in a technical milieu which
which is where we are some of the people
have to know things some of the
technical people on your staff have to
be just have a wild childlike curiosity
where they demand to understand
everything everything in other words
they need some physicists now
saying this from from long experience
there's something about the physics
discipline that manages to capture the
most arrogant people in the university
yes not surprisingly such people are not
always welcomed inside engineering
houses and you're laughing but it's
absolutely true it turns out we're very
dangerous people in industrial
environment it's the physicists who walk
out the door with your technology they
understand it and they walk out the door
and they start a company and of course
that's very good for starting companies
but very bad for for defending your own
company against that's intellectual
property theft now so the industrial
value of an omnivorous person is
actually problematical and has been from
the very beginning actually at least I
think so
that's my experience having worked in
industrial environments myself this is
true by the way even inside nuclear
weapons laboratories people who know
lots of things are really not welcome
because they're dangerous there at that
case they're dangerous to national
security know our our value especially
in engineering school is actually to
parents now people who run universities
of course like to hear that okay because
they're the money the cash cow a part of
our business is undergraduate education
but it's actually true there's a joke in
physics that in science you make you
garner power by telling people what you
know whereas in engineering you garner
people by preventing them from knowing
what you know this is of course not a
joke it's actually true very good
engineers know a lot of things that they
don't tell you
unfortunately that behavior is
fundamentally incompatible with the
entire concept of Education so in an
engineering school like MIT and other
schools that have engineering sides to
them you have a fundamental conflict
because between the needs of the
industrial buyers on the one hand and
the needs of the parents and the other
and those of us who are in the knowledge
business are actually serving the causes
of Education which is to say the causes
of parents this is the reason why you
can't close the physics department a lot
of universities are doing just that
they're closing their physics
departments but at engineering school
like MIT cannot close its engineering
departments because we are the
Renaissance people of the technical
world it is a physicist who will tell
you clearly intersting works and
probably only a physicist thus our
future is tied with clarity with
omnivorous interests with understanding
things that are other people's quasi
property basically being an arrogant
know-it-all at least I think so and
that's the way I've been pushing my own
departments at Stanford and I think
that's the underlying impetus of the
Green Center the younger people who will
fill it have a job to do and their job
is to create intellectualism in an
industrial environment that is
fundamentally hostile to intellectualism
now I want to talk a little bit more
about that that hostility because it's
it's very important to the the task
ahead both for the physics departments
generally and for younger faculty Tom
mentioned I written written a book well
I've discovered you know I'm physicists
I'm one of the arrogant people I've been
talking about I have many hats and one
of them turns out to be literary okay
and you know there's an old story you've
got lemons you make lemonade well you
know I found I could write and it makes
money so hey well I have a new new
product coming out we're in contract in
New York now it actually was coming out
in Germany first but this is a mere
detail called crime of reason and this
this new book is very very relevant to
the thing we're discussing today which
is knowing things the book is very dark
it the premise is that the
sequesteration of knowledge that has
happened during my lifetime has become
so severe and has accelerated so much
that it's actually now against the law
to figure out certain things for
yourself now physicists normally don't
don't think about that too much because
you know we're very arrogant people we
think we have a right to understand
everything but if you think about it a
minute there are some kinds of physics
that are obviously very very important
that you never talk about you never
think about the computer codes to
calculate that thing don't exist okay
well when you get inside the fence of a
weapons laboratory you'll understand why
those particular things were identified
as highly dangerous knowledge in 1954
and and expressly banned from the public
domain by the Atomic Energy Act of 1954
now I can't tell you what those things
are because telling you what's banned is
itself a violation of the Atomic Energy
Act of 1954 but you're very very smart
people so you can figure it out for
yourself
okay just ask yourself where are the
holes okay where are the things you
don't talk about and there you are now
it is part of the cultural transition
that happened when the nuclear weapon
was invented that our society what will
let's say generally Western society
generally decided that there were
certain kinds of scientific knowledge
that were simply too dangerous to be
widely known and you had to get rid of
them and you had to prevent people
financially from figuring them out you
had to cut off their grants basically
stop research in those particular areas
know who decides where those places are
well of course that's the problem in the
case of nuclear technology the really
dangerous things that were banned of
course were well identified at the time
because the technology was already
mature but other things that came later
it's less clear less clear there are big
hunks of semiconductor technology which
are completely off limits okay there are
big hunks of laser technology that are
completely off limits now these are not
banned by the Atomic Energy Act so I not
violating any laws by talking about them
so that means and in physics as a
practical matter the the idea of physics
physicists as people who know everything
is in conflict fundamentally not only
with trends historically but the law the
law it's actually against the law to
think about things there there's a
famous case there number there number of
them are the most famous is the Marlin
hydrogen bomb case where a journalist
named Howard Moreland published a piece
about guesses about how hydrogen bombs
work that the the FBI stopped or
attempted to stop but actually didn't
succeed in doing so and the judge in the
case basically affirmed the idea that
the safety of the public against certain
kinds of technology overrode manifestly
overrode the right to speech and
moreover the right to even think about
it okay now you might ask
isn't that a civil rights issue and
indeed it is it's a civil rights issue
that has never played out in the courts
for a reason you can guess let's say
from the one holy case that that those
kinds of things might have brought the
court
strike down the Atomic Energy Act and
the people whose job it is to protect
security really don't want that okay so
as a practical matter what's happened
over let's say since since 1950 is that
the potential confrontations of
intellectual freedom on the one hand and
national security on the other have been
voided Attorney General John Ashcroft
made a statement quite amazing he said
that in the entire 50 years the criminal
provisions of the Atomic Energy Act had
only been prosecuted in court twice okay
now let's say the non Espionage ones and
let us guess that it is not not feasible
that there were only two violations so
it's not too hard to guess that the
atomic energy probably is in fundamental
conflict with the First Amendment now
that's that's a matter that's that's
played out in physics but of course not
completely because it's repeating itself
now in biology and those of you who have
biology interests know
that there's disappearing knowledge in
the case of biology also right now
although it's not forbidden by statute
it's actually disappearing by virtue of
the funding algorithm just you can't get
money to do certain things it's very
hard for example word on the street is
it's very hard to get bacteria money so
that the people who pay for biological
research are happy for you to work on
eukaryotes not so happy to work on
organisms that might be highly highly
dangerous now there's also the little
matter of private property and as you
know we've had madly accelerating well
let's say strengthening the
strengthening of intellectual property
laws in the past 15 years basically as
defense against IP transfer across the
Pacific and that means that the most
amazing things are becoming patented for
example Microsoft has patented the verb
I'm not making this up and singular has
patented the smiley amazon.com has
invented that has patented the entire
idea of the checkout basket on your
computer
could we patent Maxwell's equations
today I think so I think you could you
could make it illegal you can make it
against the crazy-good copyright
violation to have that shirt right there
it doesn't matter if God said it the
Supreme Court says no well so is this
historical trend correlated with the
stress we've all been feeling in physics
as it gets harder and harder to raise
money to make things clearer okay well
that's a matter of debate but my own
personal opinion is yes I think there
are different sides of the same coin
and that the era that we're in right now
and still in is an era of darkness in
which the entire idea of public domain
knowledge is being rejected by people
very high up in our society and
implemented in the laws now what will
happen in the future of course hasn't
hasn't played out yet and I guess that's
kind of what's on my mind here I think
of myself as a physicist I think of
myself as a rather revolutionary person
of course the physicists that we revere
are all fairly revolutionary people but
revolutionary in the sense of something
a little deeper and more important and
more global and that is physics
departments are the place in a Technical
University where the entire Western
concept of the light of knowledge is
safe because physicists cannot live
without understanding things it is
hateful to a physicist to let something
remain understood and that means that
physicists are tailor-made to be
troublemakers when it comes to the
sequesteration of knowledge now whether
that will make our society safer and
more healthy in the long run or more
dangerous in the long run I don't know
but I do know that that's the mission as
the cloud of darkness descends over
technical knowledge in the world it's
our job as a discipline of science and
discipline but discipline of engineering
also to make sure it doesn't go out
in other words our job is to make sure
that the concept of reason science of
reason does not perish from the earth
so you younger people who are populating
that center up there
I'm sure you'll mostly go around about
your your your business as usual because
that's what they do but please please
keep in mind that the clock is ticking
we have a number of more difficult years
to go through in my opinion and there
will be incredible pressures on people
to specialize and not explain things to
each other because that's what people
afraid of knowledge want that's how you
manage a corporation how you keep your
engineering safe as you make sure people
don't talk to each other so I think what
you have to do is create something new
something that everybody else in
technical life and universities is
trying to create also but unfortunately
we don't have a nice big center in which
to do it
therefore the donors and the management
team of the university have given you
the tool to do something really great
and important historically the rest is
up to you Godspeed
[Applause]
so our our next speaker Steve Weinberg I
think is truly a renaissance physicist
he is the Joe Siri gentle professor of
physics at the University of Texas
Austin and his imprint can be found
everywhere in modern reductivist physics
in particle physics in astrophysics and
in cosmology more and more as time goes
on
he has emerged as a spokesman for
secular human values and high culture in
a world that's been swept by darker
forces Steve was the visiting professor
here and then professor of physics at
MIT from 1967 to 1973 this was a period
of profound change in elementary
particle physics and he played a central
role and in many aspects the central
role in that revolution we like to think
that on one of the slate Bach boards
still hanging in the CTP perhaps in some
graduate students office now in 1967
Steve first wrote down the equations
that have come to be known as the
standard model of particle physics we
often invoke this idea when the
construction team was threatening to
throw away some of the blackboard
because we didn't know which one it was
we made sure that and therefore they all
had to be preserved and reused in
students and faculty offices
Steve's paper in 1967 a model of hadrons
marks the birth of excuse me
it says leptons there to model of
leptons if only with then we had a model
of hadrons marks the birth of the modern
era in particle physics and was the
first unification of forces since
Faraday and Maxwell unified electricity
and magnetism in the 19th century it led
to a Nobel Prize that he shared with
Abdus Salam and Shelly Glashow in 1979
last week I was at a meeting concerning
Islamic Physics in which Abdul Salam was
mentioned he is
without doubt the leading Pakistani
physicist in history he is also not
honored in his country because he was a
member of a minority sect in the Muslim
world and when he was being discussed
the person who was talking about him
said that he was a recipient of one of
the really big Nobel prizes of the 20th
century
Steve's contributions to physics are
really far too numerous to mention here
so I'm just going to mention one as an
icon in 1988 he wrote a paper in which
he made a prediction of the energy debt
the dark energy density in the universe
based on anthropic arguments in recent
years observations of the cosmic
microwave background radiation have
proved that prediction correct 70% of
the universe is in this mysterious form
of dark energy now this is to my as far
as I know the only successful prediction
that's been made on the basis of
anthropic logic but also it ranks second
in scope only to Alan Guth in the
prediction in the scope of his
predictions he predicted the identity of
70% of the energy in the universe and of
course Alan through inflation predicted
the total energy in the universe so
pretty good Steve
more recently Steve's been playing in
the big leagues of culture wars that
have swept the academic and political
world over the past years and in fact if
you go online you can read of many books
and you can read many book
interviews and opinion pieces that Steve
is written and they're wonderful fonts
of both wisdom and human sympathy I'll
just quote briefly from one Steve was
reviewing a book that had been written
several years ago by Stephen Wolfram
introducing a new paradigm for modern
science it's about 700 pages in 20
pounds and Steve wrote of quite a
restrained review and a polite and
restrained review at at the end Wolfram
was advocating Wolfram's a computer
scientist and wolf was Wolfram was
advocating that the universe should be
viewed as a giant computer and Steve
closes his a review by saying so might a
carpenter looking at the moon
suppose that it is made of wood and so
with that let me introduce Steve
Weinberg
thank you very much Bob as others have
said it's it's wonderful to be back and
thanks for having me here in thinking
over this talk I I was flooded by happy
memories of my time here and so I'm
going to burden you and at least the
first part of my talk was a number of
personal reminiscences and at the same
time keep you from your lunch a century
ago when I decided to become a
theoretical physicist I felt to some
extent that I was taking the veil I was
very I loved physics but at the same
time I was attracted to public affairs
with the opportunity to do some good in
the real world and I regretted giving
that up I knew of course of physicists
who had been very active in the real
world in world war ii Oppenheimer and
Robbie for example in the United States
Lindemann and RV Jones in Britain but it
seemed to me that those who had remained
influential after the war did so at some
cost to their own research I didn't want
to pay that price and I didn't think I
would be very good anyway as an insider
dealing with government officials at MIT
I learned that there was a different
mode of being active in public affairs
that it was possible to work as an
outsider giving technical advice to the
public and in some cases to Congress
rather than as an insider advising
government officials one I'm going to
mention two examples of this both of
them centered here at MIT the first is
the missile defense debate in
March 1979 President Nixon announced
that the US was going to deploy a
massive new anti-ballistic missile
system called the safeguard system at 12
sites in America which would have given
at least nominally complete coverage of
the continental United States Senator
Edward Kennedy asked Jerry Wiesner who
was then Provost of MIT and Abram Shay's
from the local law school up the river
to prepare a book that would provide
technical advice for the public and for
Congress assessing this proposal judging
its wisdom and Jerry Wiesner asked me to
help in a small way with preparing the
book along with Abe Shay's I jumped at
the chance I had done a little work on
missile defense as a member of the Jason
group of consultants and like many other
people I had come to feel that this was
a terrible idea both because it would be
largely ineffective and that to the
extent that it seemed effective to the
Soviets it would only lead them to
increase the number of missiles aimed at
us and/or to increase their like
leanness to use them in a crisis we
asked a number of other people to
contribute to this some at MIT
Bernie Feld JCR Licklider I never found
out what those initials were for and
George Raft James and it's
characteristic of MIT that the
boundaries between different departments
it seems to me are more permeable here
than any other University I've been at
Jerry was of course Jerry Wiesner was of
course an electrical engineer I think
Licklider was probably in
Terkel engineering these days he would
be in Computer Sciences Bernie Feld was
in the physics department George Raft
James was in the Center for
International Studies and we also got
some support from people outside MIT
Hans bethe Carl Kaizen Bill Moyers and
Arthur Goldberg in the end the safeguard
system was not deployed I don't think it
was very much because of our book by the
way our book came out with a really
snappy title
it was ABM an evaluation of the decision
to deploy an anti-ballistic missile
system and then it was translated into
German with the title rocket and Krieg
rocket Wars well the the system was not
deployed I don't think it was because of
our book but because to the surprise of
everyone both Pro and anti ABM people
who lived in the suburbs in America
where the missile sites were going to be
located decided they didn't want
anti-missile missiles in their
neighborhood and that killed it much
more effectively than any Lerner darg
ument that we were able to provide the
other example comes it came out of the
student unrest in the 1968-69
academic year partly as a response to
that unrest in December 1968 about 50
faculty members including from the
physics department Viki Weisskopf Herman
Feshbach Francis Lowe Kurt Godfried and
me prepared a statement calling and and
we called for and I quote scientists and
engineers at MIT and throughout the
country to unite for concerted action
and leadership to initiate a critical
and continued examination of
governmental policy in areas where
science and technology are of ax
or potential significance and in a way
that I don't think would have been
possible at any other University this
actually crystallized into an
organization the Union of Concerned
Scientists which survives to the present
Herman Feshbach and Frances Lowe were
briefly the first and second chairman
and then Henry Kendall took over for a
number of years
Henry's a main interest at least at
first was in the dangers of nuclear
power but the scope of the ucs I'll use
that abbreviation expanded to include
the national defense policy science
policy and it expanded further under
Curt Godfrey chairmanship he became
chairman in 1999 now and includes things
like the of just the issue that was
raised in a question to Shirley Jackson
the issue of the kind of voice the
response of government to the voice of
science the Union of Concerned
Scientists is is highly effective I
think it is probably the most effective
voice of science on public issues in
America although there are others it's
it's statements it's it's reports are
competent it only comments on issues
that that are within its scope of
expertise so it doesn't make statements
about the war in Iraq or things like
that it their statements are honest it
doesn't shade its conclusions for a
predetermined aim and it's nonpartisan
we need more organizations like the
Union of Concerned Scientists to deal
with other issues other public issues on
which the public and Congress need
expert advice and I'm just going to
mention two of them which are close to
my heart but I'm sure you can think of
others
one of them is space policy since its
founding NASA has emphasized putting
people into space rather than having
people or unmanned vehicles do science
in space and this is not a good way to
do science there's not much that people
can do in space that can't be done
better and much more in much cheaper by
unmanned robots or satellites people
radiate heat they bump into things and
they're very expensive they need food
air and water and unlike robots people
want to come back which is a real
complication
now NASA has sponsored great astronomy a
the things sponsored by NASA are partly
responsible for making this it's almost
a cliche now to say it's a golden age
for cosmology but all from unmanned
vehicles the Hubble Space Telescope the
Wilkinson microwave and and I saw trippy
probe and so on and in the area of
planetary physics the unmanned Rovers
growing around Mars astronomers and
astrophysicists have generally been
unwilling to criticize NASA because of
its what I regard is an infantile
emphasis on manned space flight because
they have felt as obviously NASA
officials feel that putting people into
space appeals to the public and thereby
increases NASA's budget and some of the
money from that budget goes into real
science but this tacit bargain I think
is now unraveling the moon Mars mission
announced by President Bush is enormous
ly costly hundreds not only hundreds of
billions of dollars I think close to a
trillion dollars
and you know a trillion here at Trillium
there it adds up and NASA is in response
cutting back on science and you see this
in many areas from the study of climate
change both both by satellites and by
observing stations here on earth and all
the way to the study of the Cosmic
Microwave Background
there are many proposals which NASA's
solicited and which it was going to go
ahead with under the beyond Einstein
program which are simply going to be
deferred or perhaps canceled a good
example of this relates directly to MIT
Sam ting of MIT has developed a cosmic
ray Observatory called AMS I think that
stands for advanced magnetic
spectrograph and I'm not sure with the a
what the a stands for what is it
alpha magnetic spend in constructing
this and it is constructed not by NASA
but mostly by a European collaboration
NASA had agreed to take this instrument
up to the International Space Station if
that were done it would be possible to
observe primary cosmic rays of
high-energy directly rather than just by
observing the showers that we can see at
ground level and it would be the only
significant science ever done at the
International Space Station it's not I
mean the reason for taking it up to the
International Space Station it's not
that you need human beings there it is
not a counter example to what I said
earlier it's just that the international
space station is there above the Earth's
atmosphere it gots a lot it's got a lot
of solar power and so you might as well
use it for something
useful for once but nASA has announced
at the same shortly after the
president's announcement of his vision
that the International Space Station
from now on would be only used for
purposes furthering the president's
vision of the Moon and Mars mission and
it is apparently unwilling to commit eat
what is needed which is essentially one
quarter of one shuttle load to bring the
AMS up to the International Space
Station I think this example shows that
it's time to form an organization for
space policy like the Union of Concerned
Scientists and astronomers and
astrophysicists and physicists should
begin to speak up and challenge NASA on
these childish judgments it makes the
other example is much further from my
own interests and I speak with some
hesitation but I have checked what I've
said with experts it has to do with
economics economics of course involves
value judgments not just expertise and
that the value judgments are things for
the public in general to make but there
are some technical matters on which
economists generally agree but which get
terribly muddied in arguments over
policy and I will just give one example
there are many things that need to be
done in our country that are not being
done because there aren't any funds for
them not because we can't think of how
to do them but because there just isn't
money for them one is to fix inspect and
fix bridges and tunnels throughout the
country inspect imports for everything
from nuclear weapons in freight
containers to lead paint on toys monitor
prescription drugs after the FDA has
approved them in the years following
when they go on being used break the log
jam in the United States Patent
provide drug rehabilitation for drug
addicts who asked for it just amazing to
me that we have this enormous criminal
justice system which punishes drug
addicts and we don't provide
rehabilitation for people who want to be
cured of their addiction have it
something like the world war ii GI bill
which provides educational benefits of
the sort awarded after world war ii to
all our veterans both so that people
will be more willing to serve and also
so that after their service we will have
a more educated workforce sometimes it's
hard to argue for scientific projects
which cost millions or tens or hundreds
of millions of dollars when there are
all these other needs which are not
being funded we need all of those
including the scientific projects many
people will agree with the most of the
items on this list but it's often said
that although these things are
worthwhile we can't do them because we
need to cut taxes in order to stimulate
the economy or we can't raise taxes
because that would hurt the economy and
the the economy is the thing which
allows everything else to be done now
I've spoken to a number of economists
including one distinguished one from MIT
and I'm told that this is a fallacy and
it's sort of obviously a fallacy in the
short run a dollar that is spent by
government has precisely the same effect
on the economy as a dollar which is
freed by tax cuts to be spent in the
private economy the only difference is
whether you get public goods or private
goods for the dollar but as far as the
effect on the economy it's the same
whether I'm considering I'm comparing a
gut a dollar
tax cut with the dollar spent by
government because they have identical
effects on the deficit and I'm claiming
they have and I'm told they have
identical effects on say employment or
other indices of the economy actually I
was told that a dollar spent by
government is slightly more effective
because a dollar tax cuts some fraction
of it would be saved but the difference
is very small now of course the choice
between public goods and private goods
is a choice for voters it's it's not a
choice for professional economists much
less for physicists but it is a choice
that should be made without the illusion
that there is something about the
private economy which is uniquely
healthy in a way that the public sector
is not and I think it is time on such
issues for the public and Congress to
get better advice from the economic
profession perhaps it's time for a union
of concerned economists well as I said
it is wonderful to be back here but for
me it's also sad because so many of the
people that I knew here at MIT in the
late 60s and early 70s are now gone
certainly too many to list but I want to
mention three who were important to me
and for whom posthumously I'd like to
say thanks
one is Dave fresh who when visiting
Copenhagen where I was a first year
graduate student gave me my first
research problem
another is Vicky vice cough who brought
me to MIT and
as Francis Lowe who was a never-ending
source of wisdom on physics and much
else Francis and Natalie were enormous
ly friendly to my wife Louise and to me
and we love them I was very sorry that I
was in Europe at the time of France of
the memorial for Francis Lowe and one of
the reasons I was glad to be able to
come here today is that I would it would
give me a chance to make up for that and
to say how much I miss him and Natalie
as well as Vicki and Dave but life goes
on and I see there is a new generation
of brilliant theorists here at MIT I had
dinner last night with a number of them
and thoroughly enjoyed that and now they
have a wonderful new center in which to
do their work and I congratulate them
for this for the opportunity of working
here and thank you and wish you for
lunch Bon Appetit
[Applause]
we do have time for questions or
comments if anyone wishes to say
something Bob you kept talking about
physics with a small P and I was
wondering what is physics with a large P
what is the distinction Robin that's
just jargon for that I thought everybody
knew what I meant just in case i didn't
that physics with a big p at stanford
has to do with departmental warfare Yeah
right
let me tell you I can't since I've got
the microphone I get to tell you a joke
now one of my one of my best students
ever is John bacala son Safi who's now
in the area now running a biotech
company and he said you know I've got
Stanford figured out he said we have in
Stanford we have two physics departments
we have the department of physics we
have the Department of Applied Physics
and we have the department of unapplied
physics ok now that's what I mean with
by physics with a large P I can add to
this that a long time ago when I was
thinking about taking a job at Princeton
Murph Goldberger described Princeton
physics to me by saying at Princeton we
do physics with a capital F
max I have another question for Bob
Laughlin we've heard a number of
slightly gloomy and cautionary remarks
throughout the morning here and I was
wondering on the topic of knowledge
sequestration whether you feel that
there is also a glimmer of hope coming
from the internet and the globalization
of information where it becomes harder
and harder even for an entire nation to
stifle information that can become
accessible from somewhere else this is
not the time to have a discussion on
that because we're talking about the
Green Center but since you asked the
question just just very tersely know the
Internet has an economics problem and
the problem is that the communication is
free and you notice what's happening
with it it's filling up with garbage ok
and what is the end point of that I'm
reasonably sure is another version of
television in which there's tons of
information on the internet but no
knowledge actually when it comes to
industrial things lawyers have teams of
people preventing the knowledge from
being accessible on the internet if you
put on the internet they'll sue you and
of course there's disinformation as well
now so no I don't think the Internet is
the revolution that everybody thought it
was and then I reiterate that in this
rapidly changing time you can't evade
the responsibility as a physicist to be
the Renaissance person that the
engineering university needs it's very
very important
[Music]
let me just add to that Bruno that one
of the most enlightened things that the
Department of Energy has done for the
last 60 years is continuously support
theoretical fundamental physics at MIT
[Applause]
I'm I have mixed feelings about the
Department of Energy like everybody else
but let me make a prediction and since
I'm gonna put on my Livermore hat now of
all the many faults that Livermore has
the big laser is not one of them I think
what's going to happen soon is it
they're going to make a pellet go off
when that happens it will change the
world
it will there will be banner headlines
in the New York Times and suddenly
people's thinking about the physics and
its relevance to the energy future will
have 180 degree shift now of course I'm
a theorist so I make concrete
predictions so either that happens or it
doesn't I'm willing to take bets
other questions or comments well if not
let me thank everybody the organizers
and speakers and everyone enjoy lunch
and there's a dedication ceremony at
2:30 in the atrium on top of the Sol
LeWitt art thank you
[Applause]